hi i'm stacy with khan academy and today
i'm going to show you how students will
navigate our new mastery view within the
learning platform
students will no longer need to navigate
to a course homepage or to their learner
homepage in order to find the work that
they would like to focus on
navigation is now very easy to do from
this learning screen so that students
can focus on learning not navigation
when students are working within khan
academy their screen will look just like
this one
this left side menu opens by default but
if students prefer a focused content
experience they can hide this menu by
clicking on the arrow pointing to the
left
whenever students are ready they can
always open that menu backup by once
again clicking on the arrow
notice that there is now a menu at the
top of the left side screen
dedicated to assignments
the assignments in this menu appear in
order of due date regardless of whether
or not the student has completed them so
students are always seeing the next
assignment that is due
notice that in my list my assignments
are organized by due date on the left
navigation menu all experiences are
listed in chronological order as
students work through course mastery
this is especially helpful when students
are looking for content to support
exercises that they may be working on
notice that this exercise is preceded by
an article
and two instructional videos
that communicates to the student
that those videos and that article
inform the content with which they will
be practicing during this exercise
if students have been given an
instruction by their teacher to focus
solely on completing exercises which
they can easily identify by looking for
a mastery tower
they can find their next exercise by
using these arrows to click to the left
and the right to navigate to lessons
that are within this unit
if i click to the left
i'll go to the previous lesson and i can
see the exercise available there
and if i click to the right i'll move to
future lessons where i'm also able to
identify content that i still need to
complete
in this view
mastery levels are easy for students to
identify by looking for the mastery
tower next to each exercise
students can use these bars to focus
their practice as they work toward full
mastery of each skill within the course
notice that if a student is working on
course mastery and their course mastery
goal does not match the course with
which their assignments are being pulled
from
the students will see different titles
in this case my course mastery goal is
set to get ready for 8th grade
so as i navigate that content i'm
looking at content from the get ready
for 8th grade course
my assignments that were given by my
teacher
are being given from the full 8th grade
math class content
so if i'm choosing to work on my
self-paced learning journey through
course mastery
as i complete exercises i'm going to
want to click on the up next button
this up next button is going to take me
to the next exercise video or article
within this course mastery view
however if i click on the blue button
titled next assignment it's going to
take me to the next assignment that's
available from my teacher
we hope that you enjoy the new master
review within the learning platform and
that it makes navigation easy as you
continue to work on your learning
journey
you